[Music]
all right uh welcome everyone this is
grandmaster alexander lenderman with uh
with the first um lesson on insane and
endgame and
the
topic in today's lesson will be
uh the principle of two weaknesses so um
you know in order to
let's say be able to convert and win a
winning endgame
um we have to
create a few weaknesses
to be able to win the game right one
weakness is usually not enough to be
able to
win the game but if we if we create like
two advantages
then
there's a good chance to win the game so
this is actually the first two games
i'll show you are my last two rounds in
the us open which i was able to win
a few months ago
this is a game i played against
john burke very strong grandmaster who
just played really well the u.s
championship won the us junior last year
very strong player
and i got to this position and
i had a bigger advantage earlier i was
able to outplay him but now
uh he just his last move was bishop xf4
uh based on the tactic if i take rook
takes f4
rook d1 rook f1 queen g6
and he will be able to
get back the
material i i think i need the chat open
from youtube
one moment all right it is open actually
if you just want to resize it
oh
um let's how do i do that so
that middle button in the top right
yeah this one yeah now take it drag it
from the right
yeah it's underneath all of that
unfortunately
okay can you help me i don't know how to
one moment sorry
[Applause]
sorry for some technical things today i
guess
but
okay you like that if you like yeah okay
perfect
okay yeah we're back um
so
so yes i have a choice between um
between doing this i can play rook takes
f4 and uh i'm gonna have to give back
the knight on
on e4
or i can just let the bishop live and
keep my knight and play
uh in some other ways so here i have to
make a very important decision
which position do i go for
so what do you think
um i should do in this position and why
i think uh
the y part is also very important
okay
you can enforce a
queen trade so that you can protect your
past right here isolate upon everything
that might be uh enough of an advantage
to push trade queens like queen a1 yeah
queen f6 yeah um
all right so basically we don't want to
take on f4 any other ideas let me just i
need i think i need to refresh the
the chat maybe
we're also having a lot of issues with
the chat tonight you may not be able to
see anybody there's lots of server
problems on youtube oh really oh
us okay so there's
some might not be able to see the chat
and they had some issues last hour okay
okay
oh i think i see something yeah rook f2
attacking the bishop and putting
pressure on f7
okay um
yeah so there's yeah there are several
things we can do
but um yeah long story short i think if
we keep the bishop on
f4 on the board
it will make the win a little bit harder
because
the bishop on b8
would be doing a good job of controlling
that queening square
and uh usually it's good if the pawn
could be blockaded by uh
by a smaller piece and meanwhile black's
rooks or queens if they're still on they
can do a good job of creating counter
play
the thing is black's king is actually a
bit weaker than ours so we don't really
want to trade queens also because of
that so it's eventually i settled on
taking the bishop after all
and
and then i thought well in this case
i thought i have very good winning
chances probably it's a technical win
because number one i'm up a pawn it's
also a good uh outside past pawn and
number two
his king is very weak because a spawn
structure near the king is ruined so i
figured okay based on the principle of
two weaknesses this should give me
very good winning chances
uh in this case and thankfully i was
right
um so he played
queen e5
b4
rook b8
so i played h3
king g7
gave a check has to go here
rook f4
now i played b5 because if he takes the
pawn i can take on f7
and his king gets mated
so he played rook a7
but now i can play rook b4 so you see
how i'm able to combine the ideas of
targeting f7 targeting his king
and also bringing the rook back on b1
and
and also being able to uh shepherd my
pawn
across the board
so he played a very interesting move
here okay three
because if he goes here
rugby one
takes stakes
this is a pretty easy win because my
queen is behind the passport and
um
i will be able to play b6 most likely b7
and
and then eventually
uh i should be winning because this
queen will be passive not being able to
generate
any sort of counter play
so he tried rook a3 and this is a very
very interesting trick because um
now b6 would be
a mistake
why would that be a mistake
because he could move his queen to c5
um well in that case i think it's not a
big deal we can play rook b1 or rook b5
right
um so queen c5 i think is not
such a big problem but there's a very
concrete idea that
that would make uh b6 a pretty serious
mistake
so the thing well at first of all it's
not necessarily even a bad thing if the
rook goes back and second of all i can
actually go b7 because rookie one is not
a that big of a threat because i can
actually queen
so you don't really have time to play
rook e3 so
has to be something more
powerful
for black
um it says the message is held for
review what does that mean
it says
i'll take care of it okay
yes i think liam kian gowan got it yeah
rook takes h3
b takes
here queen d5
yeah and then
the problem is you cannot get out of
checks or lose the rook for example here
you get checked here
the rook is not a vulnerable square king
g1 we go queen c5
and queen g2 we go queen d1 and you just
cannot ever escape checks or
or if you do you're gonna lose the rook
so this suddenly becomes a draw so rook
a3 was a very sneaky idea so whenever
you know you play chess and they play a
move you have to always try to
understand what are all of their ideas
right rook a3 was a very nice sneaky
move
he played so
that's why i played the move
queen d1
because i wanted to cover the d5 square
um as it turned out it was actually a
little bit inaccurate but for a very
very
deep reason which
was very hard to find i'm not sure if um
too many people would spot it but
i could have tried rugby one that was a
little better and after queen e4
renewing the threat of rook h3
i can go king h2 queen e5 king g1 and
then i'm escaping with queen f2
but somehow i thought queen d1 is
simpler because i thought
i saw an idea that if he plays uh rookie
three
i will give a check
give a check and then this mate
queen of eight queen f7 and so on and so
forth
and uh rook h3 does not work if rook a1
i can still go rugby one
not a big deal
and uh
and even rook g3 i saw
but then i thought queen d3 queen e1
here queen b4 and then queen d8 and
queen b8 and my idea is simple i want to
play b6 b7 b6 queen c7 and b7
and my pawn is coming through
but he had a fantastic computer move
here
uh which um
maybe i should have paid more attention
to such moves after this tournament
because
clearly what was happening in this
tournament
you know was continuing to happen in the
u.s championship which is also
ultimately what cost me so like lack of
seeing creative moves he could play this
amazing with king e7
and here he's still very much in the
game
because now if i play b6 which is the
most natural
he can play this brook d3 here and now i
cannot get the queen to c7 so for
example this position
is not so easily winning anymore
this is already good drawing chances for
black so
and if i play rook b1 i mean then queen
e4
and then he wants to go look h3 but king
e7 is a really hard move to find
although
in a sense maybe it wasn't so difficult
like maybe
a very elite player like fabi might find
it because just because everything else
is completely losing
so
out of process of elimination you can
say okay
what if i
stop with the main threat queen d8 rook
g4
and so then you just have to be creative
to find that oh after this
then i can play
uh then i can play rook t3 so this is uh
this is something that's very nice
but thankfully he didn't spot it he
played rookie one
i played rook b1
he played rook a3 but now
i could go b6 and uh
because i didn't see any ideas for him
he
he tried to rook takes h3
but that does not really work
because my king little by little is able
to escape
and uh
yeah he has a bunch of checks but
eventually what happens is after this
and then this
i'm able to trade queens so i kind of
saw that i'm escaping so
i wasn't worried about that
so i was able to win this game
mainly because of the principle of two
weaknesses so that's very important so
that's what the lesson theme today is
so
let's look at another example
and this is a game
i played in last round against benjamin
glendora i did show it also on thursday
but
from a different perspective but
actually
what i realized is that i could have
found this creative move that i missed
in the end
to go nine out of nine in the us open
i still won the tournament clear first
but i could have really made history
if i would have thought about the
principle of two weaknesses
i had a better chance of finding this
idea so so black to play and
and win
find the winning idea
so we have king c4 we have king c6 we
have c4
any other ideas
sir what happened
yeah i'll go ahead
c4 okay so a lot of people want to play
c4 okay um
well c4
what do you want to do after knight b4
bishop takes b4 okay one takes b4
king d6 um so i think this is a little
bit risky to play like this because um
like now we're just giving him a very
strong pass pawn so this we can even
potentially play for a loss because um
now i'm bringing my king up bring the
knight back to d4 like this is already
actually good for white
a good knight against not such a good
bishop so
i think if anything you probably would
want to take here but
but even this is not winning because if
you ever go king c5 trying to go d4 i'll
go knight a6
um
so
one person on youtube did get it um i
think someone also suggested king c6
king c6 is okay but kingitu
the question is then what right because
if you go further then that the pawn
hangs
so what we need to try to do is we need
to try to create a new weakness maybe
another past pawn somehow
d4 is interesting yes but then takes and
then after this we can go k2 and our
pawns pawn is kind of located right
we're probably going to need to make a
second passport somehow to win the game
and that's why the brilliant idea is h5
double exclam
trying to go h4 because what we're
trying to do is we're taking advantage
of the fact that the pawn on g3 is not
really a defender because once this pawn
goes there's c4 and the knights cannot
protect each other
um
and
and then we want to go h4h3 right make a
new passport and once he has to deal
with two past pawns
um there's just nothing
that he can do for example um
if he plays uh knight e1 we can take
take and go king c6 and now we're going
to be able to make two pass pawns bring
the king to c4 target this make a pass
pawn on the d file and also we have the
h
h
pawn h5 pawn
and if he goes ke2 we go h4 and he
cannot take because of this
and more importantly he cannot do this
because of h3
and we're just going h2 so once we see
the idea it actually becomes a little
bit easier to work it out and calculate
right so h5 is uh is a very very nice
idea and uh no matter what white does
he's uh he's completely lost he's
probably has to settle on losing a piece
and play a lowest end game
uh there was also suggestion bishop
takes here
this is something i was considering a
little bit but
king e6 but then it's nothing so
so scary i can even play g4 f3 maybe or
kinky took f3
i was mostly looking at king c6 which
still gives good winning chances but
then we have to give up the bishop pair
which i didn't really want to do so much
so
in any event
um the draw clinched me first place so
after king of one i
i took his draw
because i didn't see h5 i didn't see a
clear win unfortunately i i didn't look
um
well enough
but yes the principle of two weaknesses
once again works in this these kind of
end games so in these kind of positions
before we start calculating going for
concrete lines
it's good to think in general terms
you know good to think about how what
you need to win a position like that and
once you know that okay i need two
weaknesses um you know and you already
kind of have a
strength here
you know that um
kind of
that you need to kind of do something
else right otherwise you're not going to
be able to win so at some point h5h4
somewhere you're going to need to to do
and it's a pity because i considered h5
in some lines but just not here
okay so let's look at some other
examples
this is a game between uh cava blanca
and the tartar takover this is a pretty
famous end game
um
so yeah here it's um so first white
plays h5 trying to create
uh one weakness
ah thank you dylan rook f6 takes takes
rook h1
king f8 rook h7
rook c6
g4
and knight c4
so
we have a one weakness g6 pawn i guess
our rook is pretty active but his rook
and knight are also pretty active
see when g5
so i guess one weakness of his is that
you know the king is cut off right so
that's
one thing going for us
so black already has to be careful but
this is not lost yet and if black played
uh better move knight d1
this is kind of okay for black but black
played knight f5 which is an inaccurate
move
so now the question is
how should white continue here
find the best plan for white
bishop b5 uh then we lose the pawn on c3
i think
otherwise yeah it would be good would
have been a good move had it not been
for
the the pawn hanging so
so
yeah if you suggest the move try to also
give a follow-up
what's your next move after he plays the
most
obvious move
uh
yes uh great wolf got it yes bishop
takes f5
g takes f5 and also joshua cares so few
people got it so we need to create a
second weakness right in other words we
need to activate our kings so not only
is our rook very active but also our
king and his king is passive and we make
a past pawn right so it's ready several
weaknesses to work with right and now we
have a
very good chance of
winning the game so
rook takes c3 king h4
if rook c1 we go king h5 king g6
and if rook f3 we go here here king g5
and
and king of six here
and white was able to
win a pretty convincing game after this
just took all the pawns because of how
activist kik and rook were
all right so let's see the next one
this was a game between tigran
petrossian and
a lower rated player i'm not sure if he
was a gm but
um
petrosian kind of outplayed his opponent
won the pawn
okay black got the pawn back but
white is more active rook c7 a nice
trick
r8 yeah okay so here
the question is
what should white's plan be
okay
okay so if we do that he'll go rg8
what then
so my idea is i want to play rook a4 now
and
win the spawn um
in the long run i'm very happy if i can
exchange
um the a pawn for the a and c pawns
because what will happen then is
it will have just three and two
everything on the same side and then
it's going to be very hard to win
might not be winning
so yes we get the seventh rank but
what after
it's not so easy and for example in this
case
after okay 4 okay 3 we'll have to
abandon the 7th rank at subway anyway
so it's not
so easy
somebody else also suggested h4 but h4 i
guess we can go look here
and
h5 you can always play h6
so it's also not
so easy
because you're given counter play so i
think taking on c5 is a very natural
thing to do
but um
i like what what white did even more
uh he played rook g5
so he's threatening the spawn
and uh now the the relatively best for
black would be rook g8 but of course
rook g8 is a hard move to play but okay
if he does that we can take on c5
take on c5 take on c5
rook has to go back to a8 because a4
rook a5
and this position should be winning
because after a4
white is not only upper pawn on the
king's side but also his rook is more
active because black stroke is tied down
to this pawn on
on the fifth ring
and then we can go h4 king g2 and slowly
but surely
advance our
king side pawns
so whenever you're up a pawn and your
rook is more active in a rook end game
like this it's usually winning because
it's principle of two weaknesses there's
this extra pawn here and there's also a
weakness here which ties down the rook
so it's like two principle of two
weaknesses so this is this kind of thing
should be winning
uh but after g6 it's even more winning
because now white played rookie five
and then played rookie seven
and then that's it
black's position completely fell apart
here
and black shortly after resigned
although i have to say that even
even the move rook takes c5 still wins
takes take this is still winning
but
in a sense rook g5 is better because
you're gaining a tempo which could be
useful and
you know you're not spoiling anything if
he goes rogue g8 you get a slightly
better version of the other position
and if you place the the wrong move you
get a better version right so it's
always a good idea to play like a trappy
move where you don't spoil your position
even if um even if they play the best
move
so that's kind of important
so let's look at
the next one
um
so this is uh yeah we're gonna look at
the end game this is uh
a game between
a grand master
playing white
and jennifer you playing black
she won the us women's championship one
year the pretty big score so
um
yeah so let's let's see which one would
we start with okay let's start with this
one so black is upper pawn here
so how would you try to convert this
right
yeah so
we need to cut off the king yes exactly
and then um when they go here
we play rogue d7 no uh not christopher
you it's actually a different name uh
christopher you is y o o
and uh jennifer u is y u
so it's different name
although there are some people who are
same last name but still different
people like for example there's a wander
liang a grand master and then there's
international master jason liang
and
unrelated
both in this country but unrelated and
there's also justin liang who i think is
a master or something so
yeah i mean some especially chinese
names could be
very common right so they could be
same last name but unrelated
um
but yeah in this case it's even
different last names
yes so it's important to cut off the
king and then we push the pawn right so
again principle of the weakness that we
have an extra pawn and our king is
better more active because his king is
cut off so this is also technically
principle of two weaknesses
black played this move can
here a 5
king here
still rookie 4 was good
uh here
and now white should play king 2 would
have been the most sensible thing to do
but white played rook g3
rook g4 rook h3
alright what to do for black here
you want to defend up one fair enough
um
any any other ideas
okay interesting
look at that in a second
h4
um
well yeah rook h4 i think i'll play rook
g3 and then bring the king to e2
so the question is
are you going to be able to win the
extra pawn position if if he's going to
go king a he of one
and i would be thinking it's not winning
so we have to be
we have to
play very precisely here
oh okay i think king lear mentioned the
right move here so what we actually want
to do here is the only way to win here
is actually sacking the pawn
in the game black played this and after
king 2h 4 king f1 the game later on was
a draw
why black couldn't win anymore
but why black still had a chance even
here by playing this very nice smooth
rook e4 even giving up that pawn
but then we go king g4 king f3
rogue goes back f4 and this is still
winning
because we're going to be able to win
the f-pawn
and the white skin is going to be cut
off
um how do you know you should stack the
pawn well i think if you realize that
this kind of position
if the king gets stuff one you're not
going to be able to win here
then you can realize that this is the
only chance to stack the pawn in order
to bring the king to f3 and the rook
back and uh
pawn on f4 and then eventually you're
going to win the f2 pawn
and because of your very powerful pieces
it's still winning
so it's upper pawn and better placement
of the pieces
yeah the rook f7 you you do have but
you know i can play a move like rookie
e8 for example
then i'm gonna play a four
then i'm gonna go
yeah then i'm gonna go king f3 and then
i'm gonna bring the rook somewhere here
or a2 and i will be able to win the pawn
and your king will never be able to
really
stop it
yeah king up right
yes
tony miles makes sense okay
next one
this is a game between the lyannov and
carlson i showed to many of my students
so we're going to start off with
the end game of course
all right let's start with um
we'll start with this
relatively simple exercise
okay
which how should you recapture the
knight
very important here
make sure you think it through
um
okay make sure you explain why
um
all right i think joshua kerr has got it
um
so rook g takes g4 yeah
so yeah you guys are getting it yeah we
have to take this yes because the point
is this looks more natural to attack g3
again but that would be horrible mistake
because after rook d1 suddenly the rule
goes behind the pawn and we're gonna
we're gonna be winning
as white potentially
so we need to play here
sorry because after this we have rook d4
and then we're reading the pawn on on d6
so black played here
and this
and then rookie six only chance
okay so now king g8
we have to bring that king in the game
king e3
rook g1
and here white play d7 because king e4
king here
rook there king there he will lose the
poem so he tried d7
takes takes
so now once again it's important to
uh
remember that just because you're up a
pawn it's not going to be an easy win so
if we play
a random move like king f7 rook b5 and
our rook has to be passive
we're not going to be able to win this
because
yeah we're not going to be able to make
progress here so it's very important
to play a move like this
or rook d1 also i think works because
we're threatening rook h1 but rook g5 is
the most straightforward move because
what we're trying to do like this is um
we want to play rook h5 and we also
defend the
a5 pawn laterally
so um
this way we target his weaknesses we
keep our rook very active and we keep
his rook
uh not as powerful right so we have a
chance to create two weaknesses for
upper pawn and
we try to attack one of his pawns at
some point
so he played rugby two
because what else because if rook a6
we lose this pawn and then if we have
two against one that should be winning
and i mean because two connected past
pawns
and king e4 also we can play rook t2 so
white tried this move but now the
problem is
white is very passive here
and now we have again a situation where
um
there are pawns on both sides of the
board and
because our rook is more active and
we're up a pawn we should be able to win
and this is very it's actually very
instructive how
how magnus was able to convert this end
game
so for now white's kind of waiting
around not doing much and now he played
h3
and now he decided to defend actively so
what would happen if you would have just
defended passively
well i guess the real question is what
if what if he would have played rugby
two here not even move the h2 pawn
so black will go here
so this kind of this sample line
that i'll show you
right now kind of explains
why
being up a pawn
with a better rook placement better king
placement will be a win principle of two
weaknesses so i will just push my pawns
to the maximum
to where i don't trade off any new pawns
then i'm gonna push this pawn as well
then i'm gonna push this pawn to the end
and then finally i bring the rook to b2
and there's absolutely nothing the white
can do because any kind of rook trait is
fatal for white and uh if you go rook c
through c3 i go rogue d2 so there's just
nothing
black can do yes magnus is black yes
eliano of white magnus black
um
so lyanna realized that passive defense
would be futile
so he actually tried a different
strategy he was he decided to give up
that pawn
uh but he's banking on the fact that
now the white rook is active and this
king is a little bit tied down
so a4 rook a6 a3 and here he played the
weighting of king f3
well what else can he do if he played
the
if you played rook a4 i'll go king g6
i'll free my king and then i can go king
f5 i can give you the pawn
then i can go here
then i can give you a check
and then i can bring the king to b2
and that should be
pretty routinely
winning this position
so
um
and yeah and another thing he can try as
h4 but then takes and king g5 again the
king will get somewhere to like
and then it will be winning
so he tried king f3 not to let the king
out obviously no king h4 because the
rook h6 made here
so now black really has to think about
how to make progress right that actually
in the first glance it does not seem so
easy because
yes we're up two points but how exactly
do we win king h4 we get made it yes
so we have to be very careful it's still
never too late to lose a game if you get
careless for one move you have to always
be alert in chess
so
okay so here's an exercise what do you
think could be a good plan for black
here
there's actually technically only one
plan that wins here if you don't find
the plan you you will not be able to win
the game
okay so we have rook h2 rook h2 will not
help you because i go king g3 and you
have nothing better than going back
um if you go rook a1 pushing the pawn on
a2
then
how are you going to play after king h2
the problem is now you're stuck the king
still cannot move
uh
if you move the rook it's going to be a
theoretical draw
and even if you go g4 this guy is still
a draw
because it's a a pawn far advanced to
the end under this to the first to the
second ring
and the other pawn
is an h pawn g point would also be a
draw
all white kin needs to do is
keep the king here
and there is no way to make progress
here even up to point this is a
theoretical draw
um
so
so that's also important to know
uh
what if after
after okay one not push the pawn okay so
so how exactly do you want to play i
guess you want to play g4
uh
then i can play
let's see okay
yeah
is that a winning chance maybe maybe
this is a winning chance yeah
i still think that's a little bit hard i
mean it could be tricky there's some
vancouver positions here
uh like take take
i mean maybe this loses but maybe i can
give you a check here
and this could be like a little bit like
the ventura position like i think rook
rook here and rook b3 some something
like that side checks i mean this is
already getting a little bit technical
like i'm not 100
even sure if this is winning or not but
this definitely complicates things this
could very well be a draw like i don't
know i don't have the table base in
front of me but
it's not i mean certainly that would be
a chance for black it's better than
playing a2 obviously a2 is just a draw
immediately
but still it's not a clear cut there's a
much
simpler even if the other position is
winning there's a much simpler way to
win
um
for black
so
yeah rook h2 does not really work
because king g3
uh
remember guys the captures are not
mandatory in chess it's not checkers
um
so yeah did anyone come up with the idea
looks like no one just yet
so how does black win this
uh
sometimes in chess we need to give
something to get something right it's
important not to be too tied down
materialistically i know this is a
beautiful pawn
on the
a file but sometimes if you're really if
you want something even even dearer we
have to part with something that's good
so rook b2
because after this we can go king h4
sure we gave up beautiful pawn but now
we're going to be able to easily win
this because we're going to play h5 rook
h2 and we're going to easily now win the
h3 pawn and once we have these two
connectors on the other side this is
pretty easily winning so
eliana saw the writing on the wall so he
decided not to
start king lear i i guess i missed it
earlier because there was a lot of a lot
of chat
earlier
sorry if i missed it so
yeah so king g3
he tried a2
he played another waiting move king f3
and now
black to play
find the finishing touch
this should be easier now now that now
that we know the idea
p3 anyway i'm confused did you mean did
you mean rogue b3
um
yeah okay so king lear got it
i think king lear is a very strong
player do i remember that name some from
somewhere maybe i remember that name
from
from a long time ago on some icc
orchestra.com or something i i think
maybe i recall this name
oh
maybe not
yeah so if we play rook b1
then i actually could take the pawn i
think icc yes okay yeah that's
yeah i think i remember this name yeah i
think it's
pretty good player
king here king g2
yeah this is uh
yeah this is a this is a draw
yeah so you need to you need to queen a
one queen
rook takes a one king h4
yeah and then h5 and yeah this is uh
this is winning for black yes yes okay i
remember yeah i think yeah i remember
now yeah that's
so my memory served me correct yes
that's that's the one i was thinking
about
um that was a very long time that was
before i was even a grandmaster i've
played so many games with king lear so
many blitz games
and we played kind of on even terms as
far as i remember when i was like
fm and i am so
pretty strong pretty strong player
yeah so a1 queen so takes and king h4
uh and then broke h2 and rook b3 and
stuff like that
okay so let's look at the next game
oh it was even before i was titled yeah
i thought i vaguely remember i would
already have been an fm but either way i
was already a
fairly strong player like at least 22
2300 feet day something like that
um let me just see so
ah okay um
yeah this is uh
satovsky shanklin this uh
little bit of a long story
so
i'm not sure if we're going to get to
that one but
let's uh
look at an end game from my coach uh
he was playing black here against the
hikaru nakamura in the world open
and the question is
what do you guys think should be the
winning plan for black
the one who's playing black here
no maxim i never worked with played many
blitz games with him
when i was when when i was a grand
master but
no
never
never it was like it was never my coach
um
there is some idea bringing the king
to f3 i don't know trying to break and
check
well if we do that then he gives us a
check and then he queens right
um
well the thing is he can queen and then
he stops the mate as well
and not only that he can also go give a
check first yeah
so
unfortunately that isn't good okay king
lear got it again uh so so what's the
follow-up
edwin work yeah edwin walker also got it
yes so
yeah king e1 does not work by the way
it's most natural but then he goes
rookie eight exchanging points and then
that's it that's a draw we're not gonna
be able to win with that h pawn
uh so king e1 is a draw we can't really
actually move the king anywhere if we
move the king anywhere it could get
checked it's
you know we can lose and if king e1 we
go rookie so it's um
so it's a draw if we go h5h4 we can put
keep the king over there and it's not
going to do anything so the only way to
win here is actually a very nice
idea we need to still keep in touch with
the pawn but we also need to make sure
we shield this king so the idea is very
neat
we go rook a6
could also be rook a5 rook g5 but
basically the idea is for gold k6
king g2 we go rook g2 g6 sorry and rook
g7
and then finally we go to d7
so that we can then go king d2 and then
we can push the pawn so we're still
always in touch with that pawn and we
use that check to shift the rook over
and and then we
we're making uh
we're winning
so white
ended up giving up the pawn but
now this is uh
very easy lucina position
and white
white resigned
white resigned a few moves earlier but
okay
let's continue it's called the cena
so
the good thing is
why couldn't white move to the h file
and avoid the check um
yeah good question
um
so if he goes to the h file you can
still go rook check and then rook check
and then he's still gonna go to g7 so
that's uh
so it's only temporary for one move we
can avoid it but not for
forever
all right so let's uh look at next one
um
this is my game against uh praveen
balakrishnan
an international now he's a grandmaster
i think but
at that time he was an i am
and oh we also reached a pretty
favorable rook end game
for me
um yeah so we reached this end game
where
i'm up a porn
and i have more active rooks so once
again this should be
pretty easily winning
i decided to go ahead and try to win a
second pawn which
had its pluses and minuses because i let
his rooks activate i could have also
played h4 h5 and try to at some point
get the rook to e5 and
play for two weaknesses for example a
line i analyzed later is play this get
him to play this then go here then bring
the rook somehow to e6 and then e5
um or something like that
um
but i decided to go more concretely i
decided to win the pawn
rook a2 rook h6 rook here rook h3 here
rook f3
but it's still winning position because
we'll see shortly why
now we reach a kind of an interesting
moment right so
white has sort of consolidated his two
points but it's still not that easy
because i don't have a past four right
and my pawns are doubled and his two
points sort of control mine and his
rooks are sort of active so there's
still a little bit of technical
difficulties but of course it should be
fairly easily winning
but i found like the one idea
uh
the one way that i don't win the game
um
although later on i still won the game
but only because my opponent helped me
um
so the question is what do you think
should be the winning plan for white
again you need to make sure you
you find create another weakness right
find another weakness and opponent's
position and somehow
combine a few things
that's again the only way to do it
you have to think about what how you can
take it what else in your opponent's
position could be vulnerable
and
and take advantage of that
so rook b1 if rook b1 we go rook a2
yeah rook h6 then he goes king e7
probably
bring the king to g5 that's easier said
than done right because king g3 i can
probably take the porn
so that's also not that easy
i don't think so because rook takes h3
and uh
yeah i don't think so
yeah i mean because you're gonna have to
give back one pawn and uh
and still you don't make a passport so i
doubt it
um
so it's not that easy but the one thing
i should have realized here again i
should have been thinking about some
general things before i start to
calculate concretely i should
try to understand
general features of the position and
again in end games when the position is
quiet
before you start calculating and
analyzing you have to understand the
main features of the position and in
this position two points alone is not
enough to win i have to find some other
reason why i can win right some other
weakness of his and the biggest thing is
king king safety if i can somehow go
rook h7 and then like rook h1 rook h6
i will be able to win the game
so the most natural move would be rook
h7
really my opponent has nothing better to
do than rookie three if he goes through
ka2 i can go king g3 and then move my
rook away
so he has to take
but then i go rugby one threating rook
b6 and that's it
his king is too weak and he loses
so maybe he has to try this but
then i can go here then i go there
and now his position just his
coordination falls apart and once i win
one of these pawns
now it's a very trivial win right
because then i'm gonna get a pass pawn
and you know then it's a piece of cake
so i need to somehow break his
coordination
uh by combining a few things right
combining the fact that his rooks are
attacking my f2 but they're not in
position to defend his king and
somehow create some attack on the king
rook h7 is not strictly though in the
way but
it's kind of the idea is the same
what i should absolutely not allow here
is a trade of rooks because if i trade
rooks all of a sudden i cannot
coordinate a mating attack and then
i cannot get the rook to e5 either
like in the long run and then i cannot
win that believe it or not so once the
rooks get traded after king g1 i allowed
rook d82
all of a sudden i can this is not
winning anymore
because um after check here
and this
and this
i cannot
in any way make progress
the king just stays on e7 or e6
if he checks me and um
i cannot win any of these pawns and i
also cannot really make a past four so
despite me being up two points i cannot
do much
so that's why you have to be thinking
about these general things because then
if you think about these such things
think about oh king week you know you
can never allow rook trades so whatever
you do
don't allow rook trade so sometimes it's
helpful to know what not to do like
sometimes it's even more helpful than
knowing what to do
so actually i was still thankfully able
to win this game
using the same concept as georgie used
in his game but my opponent
could basically at some point i had to
give up the points
to try to create some winning chances
my only chance is my king is more active
um yeah and here we finally reach this
position where
uh black has to make a decision
and the decision is um
you know should he push the pawn should
we move the king what should black do
should we make a waiting move
what should black do to make a draw
um
there are two moves that make a draw
uh
and there's the rest loose
so
knowing what we just learned from the
previous one
think about it
so in order to understand what we need
to to do here we have to understand
white's potential winning idea
which i think my opponent missed
completely missed
well
d2 you think loses but why does it lose
that's the real question
well rook a1 definitely loses because
then we take and then we have a lucid
position right that's
that should yeah if we lose the pawn and
our king is cut off we're going to lose
so
king c6 is interesting yeah i mean it
needs to be calculated the real question
is what happens after d2 d2 looks very
natural
the two looks very good
but
it's a mistake it's a mistake he played
he was low on time and he didn't see my
idea
how does white win now
after d2 that's the real question why is
d2 a bad move
so if we go to d3
i can go king c6
this is not winning this is what he saw
the problem is that again i cannot make
progress with my king king here i get
checked king f8 he goes rook f1
this is not winning
but what we could do is rook g3
or rookie two one of the we can do it
either with water
i played rookie two
and now the thing is
he's stuck right and um because my next
move will be rook g2
shielding my king and then king g7 so
the same idea as georgie used
so after this we go here
not king e8 because of rook here of
course
i mean sorry rook rookie one
but we go here
king g7 king c4 g7 and the king is just
not is one temple too short had the king
been on c3 rook f1 would make a draw but
as it is
he's gonna have to either let me queen
or let me take the pawn and after that
it's very easy
just lucino position and
even easier here i even get king e8 but
anyway lucina position is pretty
straightforward
um
and so rook d2 also loses the same way
like go rook g3 king g7 so what he had
to realize is he cannot just wait i have
this
winning idea so he needed to rush with
the king
um and it turns out both king c6 and
king d6 works just in different ways
after king d6
if i would have tried cs so let's look
at king c6 first
so if king c6
i would probably end up going rogue g3
but the difference is he goes king d5
king c4
king d4
rook f1 and he's able to connect the
pawn and the king and he's in time to
stop my pawn and
i'm gonna have to give up my pawn for
his rook
and the other way around and it's going
to be a draw king against king
so he's just one temple in time
if i go to g3
and
if i try king e7
then i'm even in danger of losing
because after this he and then
f7 i'm even losing after rookie one
i can queen but he's gonna also queen
and get a winning end game
so i have to be very careful i have to
play rook d3 and king f8
and then if i have to find king e7
to make a draw
yeah so it's uh
i wouldn't go that route i think
so um
yeah well no but the reason we bring the
king to the sixth is because we need to
support the spawn right our idea is to
bring the king here and then it's easy
then after that we can just give the
rook for the pawn right
so we need to connect the king and the
pawn
and kingdom 6 also works
but in a different way now after king e8
and d2 would still lose because of f7
and then we queen would check but what
we could do is rook a one
rook takes d3 because f7 now we get
mated
so rook takes d3
king is six
and um
yeah f7 rook a8 here takes takes and
that's a draw
so the king up would draw
both moves king up withdraw but in
slightly different way
but what he had to realize is that
which moves loose right once he sees
like d2 loses and why it loses then you
start to realize okay you have to push
the king up that's the only chance
and then okay i think uh he probably
would have been able to
find the right idea even with low time
but the problem for him is he would he
did not know this idea that i can go
rookie 2 and rook g2 king g7 he just did
not know about this idea he was only
looking at rook d3 so this was very
useful for me that i knew about the
georgie game that he showed me that
because in this case that was i knew
it's my only chance and
thankfully my opponent didn't know and
uh
and and with low time it's hard to find
of course if you don't already know this
idea
um so i hope you enjoyed the lesson
today um and
i guess i'll see you guys
on thursday thanks again for a very
entertaining chat and very good answers
and a lot of participation
and
see you on thursday for
um
for
for another lecture
by me
so any last-minute questions
all right i guess in that case i
i'll go
oh yeah thank you patrick yeah maybe i
should show that
[Music]
you